- I see particular body
type on the internet
or in the media and I
know that I want that,
so I work for that.
- Like what you see on
social media and stuff,
it's just kind of like very glamorized.
- Growing up I thought like,
"Okay if I wanna be attractive,
I have to have like six packs."
- So I feel like I would be ranked last
just because I don't really
fit that type of standard.
- I mean you just get a bunch of like,
random dudes in a room and be like,
"Just go out in your underwear."
You expect it to be
really weird and awkward.
(energetic music)
(Instructor speaking)
- Okay.
- Surprise. Surprise.
- Let's see how much
people hate us right now.
(Instructor speaking)
(playful music)
- I totally understand
the audience ranking,
because if you're looking
at just physicality,
not even knowing our personalities,
or who we are,
of course, we're gonna have, you know,
sexy six-pack over here.
And you know, me over here, why not?
I think Latinos are hella sexy,
so I don't get why we're over here.
Come on guys, but I respect this.
I like it. How do y'all feel?
- Comfortable, but I don't
know at the end of the day,
it's hard for me to really judge on it.
I guess the audience has voted.
(everyone laughs)
I was expected to be
probably more down the line,
maybe like three or four.
Growing up, I was always
like, you know, told like,
"Hey man you look like a
twig or you're very skinny."
- I feel like it's pretty
okay to feel comfortable
when you're in the two slot though,
you know what I mean?
(everybody laughs)
- Yeah. Oh no, this is fine.
I'm the second hottest in the room.
I guess I'm okay with it.
- I think it makes sense
for the way that like
I think people generally view the world
just based on like what
you see in the media,
social media, whatever.
Do I think that it makes sense
for anyone as an individual?
Not necessarily.
- Yeah. I'm not shocked
because I mean when I
was younger growing up,
that's exactly the body type
that I wanted to look like.
My whole life I like
compared myself to that.
So like I think it's
expected.
So I'm not like surprised
but like I did have a little
bit more hope. (laughs)
(groovy music)
(Instructor speaking)
- How do you feel about
being like in the middle?
Do you feel like you
should be farther ahead?
- Actually, I was shocked
because growing up and stuff
like my mom always told
me that like, you know
"You'd be more attractive if you gain
a little bit more weight."
That's why like I thought
that I would be last
because the society probably just thinks
that skinny guys don't deserve love
but I feel like they do though.
- They do.
Real love
- When I was a child and stuff.
I would always compare
myself to like these older
and attractive men that
had abs and that had chest.
I didn't even know like
what I was watching,
but I was kind of like just intrigued
that I wanted to be that already.
- Like for me, I'm not
sure how old everyone is
but you know, I grew up
in the whole like ever
Abercrombie & Fitch era.
Like you walk in, it's like six pack abs
like on the wall, like I'm not gonna lie.
Like that motivated me.
Like I wanted that growing up.
Do you, and of you guys think
it's wrong to want to look
like another body type?
- Yes, because I feel, I had a similar,
you know thing to you,
where I used to be, you know
roughly like 110 pounds bigger.
And I remember people
treating me a certain way.
Dating was very tough.
People didn't want to, you
know, date the type I was.
And then I lose all this weight
and I start getting treated differently
and it really showed me
like I was the same person
and I wanted so bad to
look like a certain type
and lose a certain amount of weight.
But in the day, like I was like
I almost kind of hate the
way society's treating me
as a smaller person.
- That that's definitely
an interesting answer.
But me personally, like if I
were to answer that question
I think it's, it's fine to
want a certain body type.
'Cause for me, I just use
it as fuel, like motivation.
Like I'm just gonna try to drive as much
as I can to get to that point.
- I think for me, it's like,
there's a difference between
it being like a motivator,
something you love, something
you're passionate about
and something that can
like deeply consume you
into like a dark hole.
And it's going to that dark
hole where like check yourself.
- As a group, do you guys ever
like get any like criticism?
Or is it a lot of like self criticism?
Because sometimes your own
thoughts can like sabotage you.
- I think a lot of it
for me is self criticism.
Like I know I'm going to
like all the way over here
but like when I look in the mirror
I still see like five things, 10 things
I don't like about myself
and that I still want
to change about myself.
- Yeah.
- So a lot of it really is
self-imposed definitely influenced
by the people around you.
So I still have work to do myself.
- Absolutely got that.
I feel like that that's
always gonna be there.
- Yeah.
- But also surrounding
yourself with individuals
who like want the best
for you is also good.
- After I work out.
So I'm like, "Wow! I look like
the sexiest positive person
on this earth right now."
Like
- You are obsessed.
- Like I could like--
(everyone agreeing and applauding)
- It's true.
- I could like really
date myself if I want to
but then I'm not gonna
just because like I would
want to give people a chance,
but then like--
(everyone laughing)
- Put these guy in first position.
- But then like when I look back on it,
like sometimes I do like
have like my low days
where I'm like I look like the
trashiest rat in the garbage.
- For me personally, a lot
of like my criticism was
like projected by other peoples.
I was plus sized my whole life.
So I would like, I would get
made fun of in like elementary
and stuff like that.
They would call me like
"Ariel the Little Big Mermaid"
and stuff like that.
Or like "This kid smells"
or like, or like this kid...
Somebody farted, "Oh it
was definitely this kid."
Like I think I carry that
a lot throughout my life.
And like, I definitely
want to like get healthy
but it's no longer about like
being a certain body type.
And you know, when I lost 120 pounds,
the first thing, one of my idols,
like somebody that I
really idolized in my life,
the first thing that I heard is like,
"Oh you looked better
when you were fatter."
So it's like, you can
never please anybody.
So you just gotta like,
yeah, you just gotta do
live for yourself.
And like--
- Whatever you say.
- Do what makes you happy.
And how do you feel best
is what matters. So.
- I'm very open to being placed anywhere.
I don't know which side to go on.
So I might as well just put
myself in position three
just be in the middle maybe
- If we're ranking each other
in terms of attractiveness
I'm gonna go with the people
who I feel energy wise
who I think I'd be most attracted to
in like a hangout scenario.
- There you go man.
- Like, could I vibe?
And he's like, I don't
know if we could hang.
We were talking earlier.
So I'd put you guys more ahead.
'Cause I think in a friendship
I'd be like more attracted
to like gotta to be with you guys.
Hang out. You seem really cool.
But I think I put you at three.
- All right I'm good with.
- And then I am not in college anymore.
And I don't remember what that was like.
I don't know if we could
have a ton of stuff
to get along with
but I'll put you at four and
I hate hanging out alone.
So I'm going to five.
- Oh this is tough.
Eric I think you're an awesome dude.
I definitely think you
should be over here.
You've been like open and
warm and like if I'm broke--
(everyone laughs)
- What spot would you put me into though?
- Spot one.
- Who are you switching?
- Amari. I think you've
been in the first position
for a while.
- I'm more than happy to move.
(everyone laughs)
- Number one.
- Oh my God.
- Number two.
Go there. I just kinda--
- Scoop scoop.
and one more.
- All right.
- Myself here.
- [Avi] Perfect.
- Oh, this is weird
(everyone laughing)
- Talking like non physically.
I think personality wise,
there are definitely people in this group
that I think, you know,
much more, you know
open and outgoing in a way that like,
I wish that I could be.
A lot of my confidence is rooted
in my physical appearance
and I will be very honest with that,
but I'm actually gonna go to three.
Avi I think I will put you at a one.
Eric at a two.
- Oh.
- And then Ariel in four.
(everyone laughs)
- I'll put myself last
just because I feel like
I'm more like laid back
and reserved
and like I don't really like
take the initiative as much
and I don't really kind of
like show my personality
like to kind of like random people.
Avi I put as four just
because you're, number four
is just your vibe, your spot.
- Yeah.
(everyone laughing)
- That is the nicest way to
be like "You're the fourth."
It's just your energy.
- And then I would actually
have Omari be three,
just because like, you kind of
feel like the neutral stance
of like being like introvert
also extrovert to you.
But also because like you
kind of stand the ground
between the skinnies and
also the thiccies as well.
(everyone laughing)
I would actually put Ariel at number two.
Eric for number one
because like you embrace
like your body no matter
like what anyone else thinks.
I feel like that's the type of
like mentality I want to have
no matter what
- I loved that that was beautiful.
- [Ariel] That was so warm.
- I feel so beautiful.
- Thank you.
(Instructor speaking)
- I'm stoked about this.
I'm totally okay with this line.
I won't say no.
- [Instructor] Okay.
(everyone clapping)
(groovy music)
- Based off of like how well I got to know
each and every one of them in that sense
I do feel like it was a good fit. (laughs)
I don't know. It's really, it's hard.
- I acknowledge that
attractiveness isn't only physical.
A lot of it has to do with personality.
How you interact with other
people, how you make them feel.
I know that there are things
that I want to work on
which is why I bring to myself at a three
but then there are other
people who I felt out shine me.
- So I think the most
beautiful thing is just, yeah
it's your uniqueness.
So just own it.
This is what you have.
This is what you have to work with.
And there's nobody else like you.
- I would say
YOLO (beep)
It's you only love once.
(everyone laughing)
Be kind to yourself and (beep)
what anyone else thinks really?
Yeah
- Yeah.